-Two centrist Democrats
are holding
Joe Biden's agenda hostage,
while Republicans threaten
to crater the economy
as a negotiating tactic.
Oh, and also, we found out
that the previous president
called a White House aide
from Air Force One
to defend the size of his penis.
And I know one of those stories
is bigger than the other,
but we can do both.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
No, I just meant that one
of the stories
is bigger than the other.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it had nothing to do
with the size of your, you know.
No, I --
I didn't know a lot of people
have been saying that, no.
Okay.
Alright.
Love to Melania.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry about that. I just
think he has a lot
of free time right now.
Anyway, back to Congress.
We're living in a time
of asymmetric
partisan fighting in politics.
We have two sides,
one of which cares
about competent governance;
and the other, which is willing
to burn everything down
to gain power.
I mean, just look
at the difference
in styles
between Biden and Trump.
Biden with literally cut himself
off during primary debates,
if his answers went on too long;
and Trump will spend an hour
at a rally
meandering aimlessly
about Bobby Knight or Pavarotti
or some other B-list celebrity
he met one time at the 21 Club.
[ As Trump ]
Luciano Pavarotti --
oh, he could sing.
He could sing and he loved food.
Loved to eat.
One time I saw him eat
two entrees and a centerpiece.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway,
Make America Great Again.
Bernie Sanders
and the Progressive Caucus
in the House are, as we speak,
standing firm in their fight
to advance a transformative
$3.5 trillion bill
that would invest in everything
from education
to housing, to healthcare,
a set of priorities they
promised voters they would pass.
Meanwhile, Senate Republicans
are refusing
to raise the debt limit,
which could lead to a default
and economic catastrophe.
I just wish there was someone
more insightful than me
who could express
the frustrating asymmetry
between the two parties --
perhaps a newspaper columnist
or a political consultant,
or someone from a think tank?
-We are so pleased to welcome
my friend Steve Van Zandt now,
author of this new memoir,
which, again, is called
"Unrequited Infatuations."
-I got to admit it's a little
depressing, at the moment,
a little frustrating.
I just got
this terrible feeling,
you know, and I've had this
for a long, long time,
that we are in a war and only
one side is fighting it.
And I've been feeling that
for decades
and it's really coming
to a very serious place, now,
where we might lose
our democracy because of it.
You know, the two, you know,
the Benedict Arnold twins,
they're not helping matters
and they're,
you know, they better --
I hope they come around.
I don't know.
I don't want to see Manchin
on TV ever again.
[ Laughing ]
I mean, I'm sick of his face.
-Oh, man, Joe Manchin,
you better watch out.
If Little Steven says he's sick
of your face,
your house boat might end up
burning down
like Artie Bucco's restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
So happy that this is
where we're at
with political commentary
right now.
I'm sick of the well-paid
consultants
and think tank pundits,
who clearly know nothing
about actual voters,
shilling for big corporations
and elite institutions.
Let's get Steve Van Zandt
a show on MSNBC.
Anybody who spent 45 years
on a tour bus
with Bruce Springsteen
is definitely used to talking
about politics.
[ As Steven ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
the factory's closed up.
I know. Yep. Yep.
Hard for veterans to find jobs.
Bruce, I'd love to get
some sleep before Portland.
[ Laughter ]
You could call the show...
...and he can do all his
interviews with politicians,
sharing a mic,
"Glory Days"-style.
[ Laughter ]
Very nice work from the graphics
department right there.
[ Laughter ]
And the thing is, he's right.
We're living in an era
of asymmetry
and Democrats need to start
taking that seriously.
Republicans ran
through a massive
and unpopular tax cut for the
wealthy and corporations
without virtually
any public debate.
Now, they're using the prospect
of a default on our debt,
which would crater our economy,
as a negotiating tactic,
something Democrats
have never done
when the shoe has been
on the other foot,
and, instead of just
abolishing the filibuster,
Democrats are scrambling
because centrists,
like Manchin and Kyrsten Sinema,
are making things
more difficult.
And you better believe,
every time Democrats fight
with each other,
Mitch McConnell laughs
like a haunted doll
in a horror movie.
Where did little Mitch go?
I -- I left him over there
on that chair.
[ As McConnell ]
Uh, I'm right here.
[ Laughter ]
You left the knives out.
[ Halting laugh ]
[ Laughter ]
That's why we need
Little Steven in D.C.
[ As Steven ]
Hey, I hear you got a problem
with a freakin' haunted doll
or some [bleep]
Maybe it needs a whack it
upside the head.
[ Laughter ]
That's my impression of him
from "Lilyhammer."
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
you've got two senators --
Joe Manchin,
who's been called a kingmaker
by fossil fuel executives
and personally profits
from the coal industry;
and Kyrsten Sinema,
who's raked in
hundreds of thousands
in donations from Big Pharma
and has been raising money
from business groups --
holding up a bill that would
tackle climate change,
establish paid family leave,
make community college
tuition free,
transform child care,
and expand access to healthcare,
among many other things.
Name one thing in this bill
you think is unpopular --
paid family leave,
child care tax credit,
dental benefits for Medicare.
You think people like
shelling out for dental care?
So, on top of spending an hour
strapped to a chair,
watching old episodes of "Maury"
on a TV suspended
from the ceiling
while a hygienist peels back
your gums with an ice pick,
floss shaming you
in a Russian accent,
you have to beg your insurance
company to cover it.
One time, I got so annoyed
with my dental insurance,
I said, [bleep] it,
and let all my teeth rot.
These are just dentures.
When I'm not on the air,
I look like this.
Okay, guys!
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was going
to be different.
Guys, you got to show me
the graphics before the show.
[ Laughter ]
Is there another version
we can use,
that's not as jarring?
[ As Giuliani ]
Don't you ever give me
Rudy teeth!
[ Laughter ]
And there's so much emphasis
on the top-line price tag,
as it that matters to anyone.
First of all, it'll be paid for
by taxing the rich.
But, more importantly,
instead of complaining
about an abstract number that
doesn't mean anything to anyone,
why don't you name
one actual thing in this bill
you don't like and would cut?
Something Manchin and Sinema
have refused to do.
That's a point Bernie
made recently.
-You ask me about compromise.
I have compromised.
The bill that should've been
passed, in my judgment,
was a $6 trillion bill.
If you take climate change
into consideration,
that's the kind of money
that we need.
We've already made
a significant compromise.
-Would you consider a number
less than $3.5 trillion?
-No. Look, we're talking
-Have you talked to Joe Manchin?
-about numbers.
You tell me what we should cut.
Tell the working families
of this country
that we don't need to make
child care affordable.
Tell the American people
and the younger people
that we should not address
the crisis of climate change
and try to save the planet.
Tell the homeless people
that we should not build
affordable housing.
Tell the young people
that we should not make
community colleges tuition-free.
-I like when Bernie
takes on the energy
of a volunteer at the co-op
when they raise prices.
[ As Sanders ]
How about you tell people
that Gala apples are suddenly
$2.99 a pound
[ Laughter ]
and that the Swiss chard
is now more expensive
than a trip to Disneyland?
Excuse me while I sell my kidney
on the black market,
so that I can afford to purchase
a tablespoon of quinoa.
[ Laughter ]
Now, on one hand, even though
I think he's incredibly wrong
and self-serving
and destructive,
you can at least
kind of understand
where Manchin is coming from.
Politically, he represents a red
state Trump won by 40 points.
But, Sinema, what are you doing?
Joe Biden won Arizona.
The Cyber Ninjas proved it
and, if we can't trust
the Cyber Ninjas,
[ Laughter ]
who can we trust?
I mean, don't tell me
you're listening
to Rudy Giuliani
on the Arizona audit.
-This chart is almost exactly
the chart that I put out
eight months --
that I gave them
eight months ago.
It has a couple of things,
I mean, a few less.
I mean, we had
about 11,000 dead people
they don't seem to have found.
-Just so you know,
I think dead people;
and I don't think
illegal aliens,
which was your biggest category,
have been gotten to yet.
This is just 50,000
in these categories, 60,000.
-This is not necessarily
about the machines.
This is about what you've always
talked about, Steve.
This is about paper.
This isn't machines.
This is basically --
I mean, what's the
biggest category here?
Mail-in votes
without ballots received.
-[ Laughs ]
-That means phony paper.
-Phony paper, you know,
like your law license.
I do appreciate that Rudy always
uses visual aids, though.
He's like Carrot Top, but,
instead of protein shakes,
he lives on a steady diet
of lead paint chips.
Phony papers is also
what Rudy uses
when he tries to make
a bank deposit.
"Sir, um, this is Camel Cash."
[ As Giuliani ]
Uh, I want to put it
in my savings account.
"Also, this is a blood bank."
Oh, well, in that case,
I need two pints, ASAP.
[ Laughter ]
Also, why is he making
that face?
Did he think the camera
was a mirror?
Was he seeing his teeth
for the first time?
[ As Giuliani ]
My dental plan
only covers the tops.
[ Laughter ]
These are the people
who will retake power,
if Democrats don't get
their [bleep] together
and pass
the transformative agenda
they promised voters
they would pass,
because we already know
what it's going to be like
if Trump or the Trump cultists
in the GOP get back into power.
In fact, every day, we find out
more about just how insane
and unhinged
the administration was,
thanks to the flood of Trump
books that keep coming out.
The latest is from a former
Trump press secretary
and chief of staff
to Melania Trump
named Stephanie Grisham.
Grisham worked
for this monstrous
administration for years
and, in the process,
she seems to have collected
some juicy tidbits
for a lucrative book deal,
like this one.
-She writes
that there's
a Trump aide in the White House
who was designated
as the Music Man,
to play him
his favorite show tunes,
including "Memory," from "Cats,"
and they would play those songs
-Oh, my God.
-when the president was
in a bit of a rage
and the music was meant
to calm him down.
-I'm pretty sure that's
the same thing they do at zoos,
to calm down the gorillas
when they have an erection.
"Uh-oh, JoJo's looking
aggressive today.
Someone play
'If I Were a Rich Man.'"
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
sometimes the zookeepers
will accidentally
put on some Barry White
and that's how you end up
with gorillas
going down on each other
at The Bronx Zoo.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, take it down!
Give them some privacy,
for God's sake.
That's how graphic it was --
we had to censor it.
[ New York accent ]
Because it's New York City,
baby!
Even our zoos gotta be blurred.
[ Laughter ]
You call your gorilla exhibit...
We call ours...
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York, baby!
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, back to Trump.
I bet, when Andrew Lloyd Webber
wrote "Cats,"
he never thought the soundtrack
would be used
to save the world
from Armageddon.
He might be the first composer
to win a Tony
and a Nobel Peace Prize.
He could actually EGONT.
[ Laughter ]
See? This is the kind of thing
we can do in an empty studio.
[ Laughter ]
We're still going to be doing
EGONT jokes
when the audience comes back.
[ Laughter ]
Was there a second button,
next to nuclear button,
labeled...
"Trump's mad at Canada for not
sending him a birthday present.
Quick, play 'Mr. Mistoffelees.'"
[ As Trump ]
Trudeau thinks he's
better than me?
Well, he won't
after I nuke Saskatchewan.
Get me the briefcase.
You bring it over here.
I'm going to press that button.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to press it.
♪ Oh! ♪
♪ Well, I never! ♪
♪ Was there ever ♪
♪ A cat so clever ♪
What was I so mad about?
[ Laughter ]
And, of course,
this dingus loved "Cats."
Lifelong New Yorker
who had access
to the best theater
the world has to offer,
and his favorite show
was the one
that was viewed predominantly
by 75-year-old tourists
bused in from Paramus,
from their
assisted living facilities.
If you've ever been
to a "Cats" performance,
you've definitely heard
at least one old guy say,
"Did that cat just say
he was Jellicle?"
Speak up!
My ear horn's on the fritz!
[ Laughter ]
That might've been one
of the most
disturbing anecdotes
from the book,
but it wasn't
the most disgusting.
You might remember
that little episode
where Trump secretly paid
hush money
to cover up an affair
with a porn star,
who, in return,
said his penis looked like Toad
from "Mario Kart."
[ As Toad ]
♪ Memory ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ All alone in the moonlight ♪
Anyway, Grisham also says,
in her book, that,
after Stormy Daniels said that,
Trump called Grisham
from Air Force One
to refute the story.
-Grisham claims that Trump tried
to assure her that his...
equipment was normal
after Stormy Daniels
described it as a character
in "Super Mario Bros."
-Normally, when someone
makes a call from a plane,
it's to say something like,
"We just landed,"
or "Tell Grandma
I'll be there soon,"
not, "That porn star was lying
and my doink doesn't look
like a Nintendo character."
[ Laughter ]
So, to recap,
the president
of the United States
used a secure phone line,
relayed through like
seven different satellites,
with some
of the most sophisticated
technology in the world,
to tell his White House aide
that his penis wasn't weird.
I'd like to think
that each satellite exploded
upon relaying the news.
[ Laughter ]
And that's what it looked like.
This is what we're facing,
if centrist Democrats,
like Manchin and Sinema,
don't stop holding
Joe Biden's agenda hostage.
Biden and Democrats
promised voters
a transformative program
that would invest in everything
from healthcare to child care,
to housing, to infrastructure,
and, now, they're trying
to deliver on that promise.
If they fail, it's very possible
we'll be looking
at another four years
of Trumpism,
whether it's Trump himself
or one of his wannabe cultists.
Those are the stakes,
and they're very real.
But centrist Dems,
backed by corporate interests,
are treating this like
it's a game, like they're...
-A character
in "Super Mario Bros."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.